Dude. I saw joker. Finally,
I saw joker finally, and it is so good.
And I know everybody thinks that, and everyone says that, but Jesus Christ, man.
Here's what I think.
I could do that. I could be that guy.
And I can have the.
Uh.
Uprising that that character has. And I think honestly,
it starts with this podcast.
And thank you beforehand, because I know these,
the babies dude, these will listen to you.
You can listen them right now in your car.
We're probably at home because it's sad and you can't go anywhere unless you're
in Missouri, but you you're my baby man.
And if I ever get in a insane asylum, you come and you break me out, man,
because I need you, dude. I'm not staying in that. Cause what I'm doing,
it's all I, I'm not evil. Okay.
What I think is that's what they did about that movie. That was so good.
They made you feel for that dude. And he was a psychopath killer,
But the whole world is different for me. Now that I have my son, man,
I watch everything different before I had my son. When I saw joker,
I'd be like, Hey, this guy. Wow, that's bad. That's crazy.
Now that I have my son, I see everyone as somebody's kid. And I get sad, dude,
I watched joker and I got sad because I'm like, man, this especially,
cause he had the part with his mom in it. And I'm like, ah, this kid,
he was just a boy at one point, you know,
I want to say everyone should have kids. Cause it, it changes your world.
And I hate when people say that, but it's so true, man.
Everyone was somebody's kid once even the joker,
Even the joker, even the real joker. Uh,
but yeah, God Joaquin Phoenix was so good. The whole movie was so good.
Todd Phillips. I don't even understand how you,
it's so hard to make a movie that's so sound and wrapped up in its own
world. And everything makes sense in that world that's created.
And when it's quote unquote a real
movie, like a movie that tries to be real,
I think it's in a way, even harder, like take the matrix one to me,
a great example of a movie that is,
that creates a world and then
it adheres to all the rules in its world. And there's no like false moments.
I mean maybe there's one or two. I don't know how to dizzy it again,
but it makes sense within itself. You know,
people argue that like star Wars is like that. I don't really watch star Wars,
but like, um, you know,
it's like a philosophy and it's hard to do that in a scifi movie obviously,
but it's so in a way easier, because you could just make up, you know,
that's why I don't like a lot of scifi movies. Cause there'll be like, ah,
the world's ending. And they're like, Oh yeah, well we in,
they just invented this thing like, Oh really? Yeah. Oh, let's use it. Well,
the thing is it's only on Mars. Oh, well let's go to Mars. Well,
the only way we can get there now because the doors are knots exploded the
things where we got to go back and dime. Ah. How do we do that? Well,
there's a thing. There's a device. Oh, okay. I didn't know that. Yeah.
Well they just made it when in the future. What?
I just came back to tell you this. Oh, okay. So you're not born yet. Nah.
And then if people are like, you know,
dorks with black Sabbath shirts or just eating popcorn, like,
well this is amazing. And so, um,
but the joke to do it in a real movie is,
is in a way harder because people are expecting realness.
It's like when people talk about the Chris Christopher Nolan,
Batman about the joker and how it was real, like, okay. Yeah,
it did kind of adapt a real newness to it.
But dude at the end,
Batman was still flying around from building to building and like had technology
that didn't exist.
But the joker or joker rather didn't do that.
It was all stuff that could possibly happen.
And the world that they created in that world was all
truthful and it was just amazing, amazing movie man.
And Todd Phillips came to see me, uh,
do stand up like a few weeks before joker came out and I was like,
I can't wait to see your movie.
And I finally saw it and I dunno if he will hear this,
but dude, I, I mean, I'm talking about,
I can't stop thinking of that movie.
I can't stop thinking about that movie and how good it was.
And here's what I think too. It should have won best picture.
I didn't see all the things,
but I saw para parasite and that movie was good and it was
very good. It, I think best screenplay. Okay. Give it to parasite. Fine.
But that movie was great,
but joker was great and also entertaining.
I thought parasite was a little bit and you know, this could,
I'm sure this was intentional. It was a little bit harder to watch because, but,
but just every moment of joker was just like, it was,
it was, it got away with being relevant socially and also entertaining,
which is like so hard. Yeah. Anyway, whatever enough of that. Uh,
since we're talking about movies, let's talk about James Bond.
I watched this video the other day. Oh my dude,
this killed me do it.
There's a video on YouTube called seven inappropriate moments.
James Bond wouldn't get away with now.
Andy.
It's on the pages, digital spy.
And they just go through seven moments that it would get there.
Like some of them was Sean Connery and the other guys and. But dude,
I just love it. How times change men.
Talk.
Turns a woman around says men talk and then slaps,
harass. And she walks away. Dude.
Imagine if Daniel Craig did that in a quantum leap or whatever
the it is. Condom solace for sake, dude.
Why did they name movies? Something that you would never know what it is.
I don't know what quantum is. I don't even barely know what solace is.
Put them together or a ghost protocol, dude. You know,
go
your self ghost protocol. Yeah.
All right, dude. Just call the movie. Jumping round.
Tom.
Hank, Tom cruise, whatever did all this old ran off a bit. That's so dude,
Tom cruise is such a big.
Good.
Successful actor that he's like, no, we're not getting stumped, man, dude,
I've done it all. I've. Every kind of thing in the world.
And I've made all the money, tie me up.
I'm swinging through that building.
So there's the, here's the other one Jesus. So loud.
Here's another one.
When he tells us he does the look when he tells the black guy.
Where's your boat about my shoes.
Turns to the black guy and says, fetch my shoes,
sell racist. Here's another one.
Oh, this, the Indian with a bunch of instancy.
If I can find out anything more about your Indian guides, good.
[Inaudible] for a few weeks. Was it.
Keep you in Curry for a few weeks?
I don't even really know honestly what that means.
If there's a few where he's like slapping women, which is just crazy to me,
this is the best one though. I thought as in worst one
In an illogical and offensive plan,
James' attempts to blend in with the locals in Japan, by becoming Japanese,
thanks to a bad wig,
fake tan eyebrow extensions and some false eyelids dude,
what is this Austin Powers? I didn't realize how.
And then he walks in.
And he says like, he walks into the undercover to the lady and he says
[inaudible] And really look more Japanese. Like
here's another one where he uses he doesn't take no for an answer. And.
Where's another one. There was another good one. I thought no, no.
That one was just makes me uncomfortable. Tries to rape a lesbian. Okay.
Um, Oh this was the one where he puts the dwarf in a
suitcase. Oh, Oh, disconnected.
We're where he puts the dwarf in a suitcase dude.
Like he's fighting.
Is that even the right thing to say dwarf.
It is what the interviewer says in a fist fight with a dwarf James
ridiculously traps knickknack. And I mean,
the fact that he's called knick-knack anyway, you know, uh,
before carrying him out of the room and he's fighting,
he liked.
[Inaudible].
He's just like walking towards him with the suitcase and then just.
And.
They cut. They cut it to him already in the suitcase,
obviously, because it would be impossible.
I mean the guy's name is knickknack prejudice.
Um, wow. You know,
imagine if you tried to get a movie done and you had a dwarf in it and his name
was knick-knack in it now. Wow. Wow.
Canceled for me, canceling me for even supposing that,
uh, I would love if Daniel could, they, I want them that.
Everyone's trying to make the most PC.
Like now they're talking about how the double of seven is going to be a woman
and how James Bond has a daughter or whatever the it is.
all that dude go extra hard,
extra hard and just be like the racist bond to where he's
just like literally says the N word in
or like just says stuff like let's because they're
stupid about like just any other race. Uh, what.
The I, the.
World would be over. If, if James Bond came out,
I'll tell you what though. No matter what they do,
there's going to be a problem. So I can't wait for that.
I can't wait for the new James Bond movie to come out with the,
with the black female double Oh seven or whatever the hell it is. I can't wait.